finale serrée jusqu'à la fin.
Aujourd'hui, pour la première
fois, elle accepte de parler
de cette soirée.
Louise Boisvert.
- C'est ça aussi, le message
d'aujourd'hui, c'est que
je vais bien. Il ne faut pas
que les gens s'inquiètent.
- Le message est fort après
10 jours de silence. Marie-Josée
Savard se remet tranquillement
de sa défaite crève-coeur.
- Mesdames et Messieurs,
la mairesse de Québec!
(applaudissements)
- Déclarée gagnante 28 minutes
après l'ouverture des premières
boîtes de scrutin le 7 novembre,
elle perdra deux heures
plus tard par un peu plus
de 800 votes.
MARIE-JOSÉE SAVARD, candidate
défaite à la mairie de Québec
- C'est clair que ce soir-là,
au moment où tent où tent où to,
j'ai eu l'impression
qu'on m'avait pris le coeur
puis qu'on me l'avait mis sur
la table. Mais un coup dit ça,
puis avec un pas de recul,
je trouve qu'il y a beaucoup
plus de positif.
- Marie-Josée Savard
ne changerait rien aux der
semaines. Elle est fière de
sa campagne, elle est fière
de son équipe. Elle choisit
de regarder devant.
- Encore là, ça ne me donnerait
rien de dire : Ah, j'étais
tellement proche! Oui, mais
ça veut justement dire qu'on a
fait une bonne campagne,
que nos idées étaient bonnes,
puis que les gens nous faisaient
confiance. Donc c'est vraiment
comme ça que j'ai le goût
de continuer, je vous dirais,
à me reconstruire.
- Elle reconnaît qu'elle a
souvent dû défendre le bilan
du maire Labeaume durant
les 52 jours de campagne :
le tramway et le patrimoine
ont ponctué les attaques
de ses adversaires.
Elle était consciente du défi
après un règne de 14 ans.
- Est-ce que ça a été
plus lourd que que je pensais?
Pas nécessairement. Du même
coup, M. Labeaume, tout le monde
pensait qu'il allait être
super présent pendant
la campagne; finpagne; finpagne,
il a vraiment été très absent.
Ça fait que ça, c'est sûr
que ça m'a amené un poids
supplémentaire parce qu'il
n'était pas nécessairement là
pour défendre le bilan,
puisqu'il n'était plus dans
la vie publique, mais en même
temps, il a tenu sa promesse,
donc...
- Elle se donne maintenant du
temps pour réinventer la suite.
Propriétaire d'un café,n café,n,
elle ne renonce pas au service
public, mais elle n'a pas
d'appétit pour la politique
à court terme.
- On est tellement de proximité
avec les gens, on peut tellement
faire une différence, donc
je ne me ferme pas de portes
'instant, mais c'est sûr
que je ne mettrai pas ma face
sur un poteau bientôt!
(rires)
- Ici Louise Boisvert,
Radio-Canada,